(hums)
(phone ringing)
Mm, hey butthole,
what's up?
Girl, did Bobby Skeltis
ever end up letting
you have sex with him?
Why? No.
Okay good, Laura just
told me he has herpes.
So...
Oh.
Well, no, that is a big relief
because no, I did not.
Okay, no, I just wanted
to let you know.
Oh my God,
oh no, no, no!
My God, no!
Please, God, let me not
have herpes, please!
Well, well, well.
Look who it is.
God?
Do you remember when the last
time I heard from you was?
It was probably pretty recently
when my friend Tig got cancer.
Pretty sure
I reached out then.
No, it was seven years ago
when you were rooting for
the Green Knight
at Medieval Times.
Oh.
Well, God, thank you so much
for coming through for me
that night.
(man)
You're welcome.
This guy, Bobby Skeltis,
that you slept with?
What are you doing?
I know, I know.
I can do so much better,
you're right.
I didn't say that.
Oh.
You know, 70% of people
who reach out to me
are having
a herpes scare.
Why should
I help you?
Okay.
That's a fair question.
Yeah.
Okay.
Um, so I'm kind of like,
a public figure now.
Mm.
Like a role model?
So if some young girl saw me
buying Valtrex or something,
it would be like, a thing.
Right.
A thing, hmm.
Like that earthquake
in Peru yesterday
that killed
9,000 people.
Oh my God, I hope
no one was hurt.
Oh, gosh.
I really need to stop
making so many white girls.
Let me be honest
with you, okay?
You did get herpes,
you already have it.
No!
Yes.
Now for me to
undo your herpes,
I have to create balance in
the universe, you understand?
Totally.
I'd have to kill off an entire
village in Uzbekistan.
Yeah, whatever
you think is best.
Do it.
You'll also have to
sacrifice something.
Oh my God, name it.
Okay.
You need to stop
drinking.
Pass.
How about stop
using hair spray?
The aerosol is very bad
for the environment.
Could I just
like, blow you?
I'm gay.
So?
Jesus Christ.
How about you just
call your mother
a little bit
more often?
That's an easy one.
Mmm... what is
herpes exactly?
It's an outbreak,
like, once a year?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think I'll
just take it.
Okay, fine.
Fine, herpes it is.
Now don't forget to call all
the men that you've slept with.
It's the moral
thing to do, right?
Oh my God, of course.
Duh.
Amy.
Mmm!
I can see everything.
What? Oh now?
You want me to
do it now?
Yes!
Okay, well, you weren't
clear about that.
I'll do it
right now.
Sor-ee.
I'm sorry,
I'll do it now.
Boop boop boop.
Boop boop...
♪ Jeans into
jean shorts ♪
What?
I'm sorry you changed seasons
and now I need jean shorts.
This one's on you.
Just call them.
No!
Fine, I'll do it.
Gimme the phone.
Unbelievable.
(Amy's voice)
Hi, Mike, it's Amy.
Schumer.
I don't talk
like that.
Uh, yeah, we met on
Christmas at the
Boston Market and had
sex after two beers?
Yeah.
You have herpes
because I have herpes.
Byeee!
Did he sound like he was at
all psyched to hear from me,
like what was his vibe?
You're the
(bleep) worst.
Wow.
Oh, no?